if there is an apocalypse or a reset
what are like the top three things that
you're glad you have you have you want a
generator you want a food supply and you
want a gun those are good anything else
in water I mean like if we went down
this prepper because I'm like prepper
I'm prepper no yeah no [ __ ] yeah
um
tribe Community family friends it's
um it's really easy like I got my gold
bag I got my gun you know I got my water
purifier you know I have a generator you
know and um cool that stuff's Gonna Last
like a week
um when it really comes to
longevity it takes it takes a community
you know it takes trusted allies
um like if you think Hunger Games like
it you really have to have a group a
connected group that are that had share
that have shared values that have shared
vision and um will be able to
collectively fight and stay together
yeah um can share food so obviously as a
hunter with my mini freezers that have
redundant power sources
um I'm gonna have what's a redundant
power source it just keeps it will never
run out of whatever but that's what just
keeps going on I don't know how the
engineering is behind that but it's
really easy engineering it is it's not
it's not hard so like
um if the pal it's the power grid
crashes right okay there is one form of
initial energy like power battery
systems that are powered by solar but
let's say you're in the middle so
apocalypse and there's not enough sun to
charge the batteries that keep the life
supporting things going then we also
have generator like whole house
generators that run off propane and
Diesel and then you have some that are
on natural gas so when I say redone I
mean redundant
um so like I will have enough meat
forever and um yeah but like I need
veggies and I need fruits but I'm not
really a farmer so back to the community
and tribe I have tons of friends in my
like click to trade that will trade yeah
that will like barter and be like cool
here's an elk backstrap can I have you
know some artichokes and some zucchini
it'd be great yeah so what
uh size of a of a community like this do
you think it takes oh 20 30 20 30. it
takes a village yeah yeah I mean yeah
prep prepping it's it's gnarly yeah
um but
people thought I was insane three years
ago
in 2019 that's right yeah and then
you know like
we're our courses are sold out for a
year and a half like I can't hire people
enough fast enough that are qualified
enough to train the number of people
that are asking all the things that I
was screaming from the rooftops three
and a half years ago you know like and
the reason it hasn't even happened yet
like that was just a little taste of
like here's something that barely kills
anybody but gets you kind of kind of a
little bitty sick yeah
um I I think it's wild that uh
the the three years you know like three
years ago people weren't hip to this you
know like uh long you got into it a
little while ago I I got into it
in
2010
2011. what you read something or my dad
was telling me that the the dollar is
gonna collapse you know like buy gold
don't uh
you know don't don't buy a house because
uh you know like the house in America is
gonna be like a a uh
cabin on a sinking ship or something
like now I don't think that America my
dad would would have everybody believe
that America is in a much worse position
should the dollar collapse but I just
think that the whole world is so
joined at the hip it's like I have a
Canadian passport so like uh
you know I've thought about oh don't go
there
yeah that's not gonna be any better yeah
I don't think I don't know that it's
good Trudeau is going to Gonna Give You
freedom
yeah but but I I think about it a lot
just in general and um weird like the
writing was on the wall a long time
before covet and then like like we
really sped up the process with covet
with yeah the money Printing and yeah
and then now with the the hiking up the
interest rates to try to combat the
inflation it feels like all we're
getting is stagflation now yeah right
meaning that like inflation's out of
control and nobody has any money yeah
yeah I
this Q4 of of 2022 retail wise I think
it's going to be a really great
indicator for people uh to recognize how
dangerous financially a lot of people
are there's a lot of debt that was
carried over from covid when people were
out of work or
um you know they're getting locked out
of their Apartments the property owner
couldn't kick them out yet because
um they're frozen uh and they weren't
allowed to kick anyone out but that
property owner now has seven properties
and six of those people haven't paid so
like that property owner is now in
bankruptcy with the brand with the bank
like all of that's going to be cascading
yeah well you saw Amazon meta and Google
they're laying off tens of thousands of
people Twitter fired 3 000 like there's
like 35 000 jobs as of today done
yeah yeah right after midterms by the
way and gas just went down no gas just
went up what but it's like two bucks
here yeah you're in Texas yeah it's like
five or six in California yeah yeah um
you're intact that's all taxes that's
California taxes meanwhile the the price
of of oil is 88 bucks a barrel yeah it's
like the lowest
it's been it was way lower in the
pandemic because nobody was driving
during the Trump era it was half what it
is right now four oh 40 yeah yeah that's
I mean typically like historically oil
is about 100 bucks a barrel you know so
there's no [ __ ] reason why gas should
be so no it's crazy this is uh
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude